- She's a 15 time Grammy
winner, a kick ass song writer,
and a humanitarian who has sold
over 40 million albums worldwide.
What?
Her latest is out.
It's called "Alicia."
Give it up for Alicia Keys, y'all.
(light music)
Yeah, you look so cool.
- Thank you, how are you?
I miss you.
- Oh man, I miss you too but I mean,
I saw you come on the
screen and I was like,
not on my best, coolest day
do I ever look as cool as you.
It's like, it's like, I mean,
I don't know how you do it, it's like,
you don't even think
about it, but whatever.
But it's a great lineup
at the BBMA's tonight.
So we've got Bad Bunny, Post
Malone, Demi Lovato, SIA
a bunch of others, you're performing.
Who are you most looking
forward to seeing?
'Cause I know people always
ask us this every year,
but this year it's kind of different.
'Cause we don't really get
to see live music a lot.
- I know, I miss it so much.
I think we're all missing it so much.
I definitely, I'm looking for,
I'm looking forward to Post.
I'm looking forward to seeing
you because you're like,
you know, you got all
this spunk and energy
and I just love your spirit.
And honestly, you know,
it's always such a,
I think it's a little bit
different because now it may be
we're performing in similar space,
it's, every time it's different.
So I'm just open to the newness
and I know we're all excited
to just hear great music and
have a good, have a good night.
- Yeah and I mean, while
we're all navigating the new,
it, at least we're being able to navigate,
at least we're at least out of our houses,
we're able to be somewhere
and actually perform.
As artists, like, you feel
like it's your duty right now.
Like your job to kind of,
you know, not distract,
but just kind of bring a
little hope, you know, more so,
but I want to talk about
this 'cause you created
a $1 billion fund to support
black owned businesses,
which is amazing.
The NFL has contributed,
how can others help?
- Absolutely.
This is a, you know,
this is a really, something I'm
very, very passionate about.
There's so many people that
are thinking like this,
thinking about this.
Obviously we know that it's the time,
we see the inequities that are happening
right in front of us.
We know that it's time to
really empower black America.
And so this is something that
is big, big, big, big for me.
I'm so, so proud.
And I feel like so many corporations,
institutions and organizations
really do want to be invited
to the table to figure
out how to contribute.
And so this is a conversation
we're gonna be having,
we're creating it now, building it all up.
The response has been unbelievable.
It's gonna be focused on black businesses
and black investments
invested by black investors.
black schools, black banks,
you know, black communities.
It's really powerful
and I love the response.
So thank you for bringing
it up and yes, I'll be,
I'll be telling you more about it a lot.
So this is the beginning.
- It's important.
And now it's the time like, you know,
I've been hearing everyone
talk about how crappy 2020 is
and yes it is but at
the same time, you know,
I think everything's
have to go just around.,
Just kind of be messy before
you can actually fix the
problem and notice how bad the problem is.
So I love that you're doing this.
I think it's very important.
All right, so Alicia's new album
is called "Alicia" and it's out right now.
So if you're smart, you'll go get it.
I just have a quick question.
I mean, is this new album a
very personal one for you?
You've you've named it after
your name, obviously, so.
- This is definitely the one
that I know myself the best.
I've totally not, I would
have never been able to call
my previous albums, "Alicia,"
just because, you know,
of course I've always been myself,
but I didn't know myself as well.
And this particular album is
really about the different
nuances and sides of us because
there's so many different
pieces that make us a whole person.
But so many times we don't get to
express those sides, right?
Like at the job, we're one way,
with our family, we're one way,
with our kids, we're one way.
When do we get to kind of
explore the parts of ourselves
we don't know?
So that's been something that
I've been learning about and,
and, and really it's, it's
poured into this music.
It's poured into the writing.
It's poured into the
diversity that you hear
and the response has been so crazy.
I've been so proud and
excited for the love
everybody has for it.
- That's really great, man,
I'm super proud of you.
That's so cool.
And everybody needs music
now more than ever, you know,
like it's, it's nice.
Feel a little hope, a little
distraction, all of it.
Well, let's, let's talk.
I wanna, I want some stories
about some of the tracks.
I was listening last
night and this morning.
And so, so maybe the most powerful song
and it's incredibly hard to listen to
if you're a mama as well
is "Perfect Way to Die."
It's the story of a
mother's grief after her son
is shot by police.
How difficult, I mean you're a mama and,
and part of the community
that's being attacked right now.
You know, so how hard is it that?
- I mean, it's devastating.
Obviously we all can see
it, no matter where we live,
no matter how we grew up, you know,
we can all see what's happening
so clearly and evidently,
and I, and I know that we're all outraged.
We're all, you know, just,
we don't accept it anymore.
You know, this is not the
way that it's supposed to be
and we will not accept it anymore.
But to write that song,
just a sliver of that
conversation, that emotion,
that feeling of, of losing your child
because somebody murdered them because
they judged them in some way
or thought they were gonna
cause harm that they weren't going to.
I mean, the grief, I can't even imagine.
There is no perfect way to die and
definitely not at the
hands of police brutality
but bringing that to the
forefront and being able to have
that be a conversation at work.
We're all talking about, thinking about,
obviously going into this election,
thinking about how do we want
to show up for ourselves,
for our communities,
what do we want to
demand from our country?
You know, it's a really
powerful conversation
to be having and, and just
the encouragement for us
to show up, to start to make
the shifts or the changes
that we we know are needed.
- Yeah, and I think we, we take advantage
that we're so lucky.
We're so fortunate to
have that vote, you know,
and I think we're, in this
country, we get so comfortable.
We get in our little
comfort zones sometimes,
and you don't realize how
important it is to vote.
Like, and anyway but Breonna
Taylor was in the video
for that song as well.
Alicia has been pushing for
justice for her and this summer,
she made another video with
Breonna's mom, Tamika Palmer,
activist, Tamika Mallory,
and the rapper Rhapsody.
So Alicia, do you feel hopeful
in the fight right now?
- You know, I mean, I'll be honest.
I, I, I'm disappointed.
I'm very disappointed, I'm frustrated.
And I think we all are.
It's just, it's just enough with the,
the actions that are
never held accountable.
It's just enough, you know, and I,
I feel like it definitely feels,
I know it's wrong and I
know that it has to change.
And I do feel inspired to
continue to show up and continue
to be an active part
of humanity, you know,
because we all have to
care about what's going on.
And that's one thing that
I do see, I truly do.
I see the whole world,
France, Paris, London, you know,
the whole of America
really for the first time
showing up and saying and
speaking loud, you know?
And, and, and so in that way,
I do feel inspired that we,
the people who do make the changes,
because I know sometimes
it's hard to believe.
You know, we think, you
know, this, this, this,
this unseen government
kind of does everything
and we have no control over it.
Sometimes we can feel like that
but we do have the power,
we do wield the power.
And so I do feel inspired
to continue going,
but I do feel disappointed
that more justice wasn't due
for Breonna and for all the people
who have lost their lives,
you know, been murdered
by police brutality.
- Agreed.
Well, you've, I want
to talk about this too.
You have so many things.
You, you're, you're just like
that lady doing everything.
I love it.
So you you've also
branched out from music.
So tell me about Keys Soulcare.
- You know, it's, it's, it's, it's a,
it's a lifestyle brand,
it's a concept, it's a thought.
It's going, it was started
with my personal journey
to find the right skin care for myself.
And it's been a tricky situation for me
since I was quite young.
And it's always been a dream
of me to create something
that would be just good for my skin,
but not only for the
outside, for the inside.
And I realized that we focus so much,
we have skin care and nail care
and body care and hair care.
We have all this care, but
we don't have soul care.
You know?
So I created a Keys Soulcare
in the essence of that
and it's gonna be many things,
but right now it's really
just about community
and it's about ritual
and it's about talking about
how can we focus on ourselves,
fill ourselves up and our souls.
And so that's why Keys Soulcare
was born and I'm excited.
- Well, here's the thing too.
I love when something is organic,
but Alicia is launching Key's
Soulcare in December, y'all,
which also happens to be the month
of my favorite holiday. Christmas.
As you know, I'm a firm believer
that the holidays can be
celebrated on any given day
of the year.
Oh my gosh, what's that noise?
Oh my gosh, it's our very first
Ambush Christmas this season.
Man, it's Christmas in October.
You're welcome.
I am being dumped on.
Everywhere, that was awesome.
It's like I'm in a video.
Well I kinda am.
Okay, so that means
it's gift time, people.
And Soulcare starts here.
Alicia Keys and Key Soulcare
want to help you give
yourself a moment of calm.
It's still snowing.
They want to give you a moment of calm
by sending everyone in the audience home
with their signature sage
and oatmeal scented candle,
it smells real nice.
Yes, I love it.
Oh my God, that smells
like peace, I love it.
Alicia's new album is called "Alicia."
Be sure to check it out.
Also check out her line
of personal care products,
Keys Soulcare, this December.
Don't forget, y'all
watch both of us tonight
on the Billboard Music Awards on NBC.